kind of broke his concentration on the  shot Julius the second most valves  committed to the attacker it be analyzed  over the offensive line what a spin what  a boom Friday people shovel pass to  Jones six on the clock can't create any  space here comes Butler down he goes and  he scores right down the middle  so 13 over 5 the turnover story  Minnesota started in 250 points seekers  good read by jeff Teague or Carl's came  right on the spot you see the foul and  the basket by Jimmy Butler goodbye Jimmy  Butler  his first basket from behind the arc  he's only made one shot tonight yeah  they're only you Bunder Neath that's a  good athletic play Tegan finds Butler  she Julius - right - Jimmy Butler this  is about as sloppy as we've seen the  Lakers with their ball security all year  the first step of the dance and then he  spots the cut man died by Jimmy Butler a  three-point opportunity rest of the year  with many circuits it's just been oh  well one breaking trances